is it true that you guys had a shared
bank account and then you like blew that
money and rented a house with it but in
that house you wrote Good Will Hunting
is that accurate that is that is a
little bit out of order but it is
accurate
we did share a bank account and I always
thought it was perfectly normal
um
we wanted to be actors and we were in
Boston we wanted to go to New York and
you know take the train up to New York
and pay for that that's to go audition
because that's where you could audition
so we were we would work a little bit we
would do extra work or a line here and
there the occasional Burger King
commercial and then take that money and
put it in the account and we both
we were friends and we wanted each other
to succeed and we love each other and so
it seemed like clear like let's do this
together and it's actually I in
retrospect really valuable because I
think kind of starting out in a field
like that can feel very lonely but we
shared that bank account like into our
20s even into when we lived and real
good wanting in a house in in Eagle Rock
uh which is a neighborhood in Los
Angeles which was at the time a very
inexpensive neighborhood and very far
from all the places you had to go to
audition and all that stuff and then
when we sold good hunting we I I was
like we are now Rich for life my needs
are over I will never have to work again
we so you know I'm rich forever i s we
sold it for six hundred thousand dollars
we split that 300 000 each and then the
agents got 30 000 so we had 270 and we
paid about you know 150 in taxes with a
hundred and ten thousand dollars
we each bought 55 000 Jeep Cherokees
um
and then had 55 000 West which naturally
we decided to rent like a five thousand
dollar a month party house on Glencoe
way up by the Hollywood Bowl and we were
broke in six months
yeah
thank you
now maybe that car lays into you have
started this company called artist
Equity this is everyone out there is
like
and this is your title card
[Applause]
yeah they see the problem is when that's
your resting face it's often
misinterpreted because here I am having
a great time
RBF
what's that what's that resting
face
I definitely have RBS if I can say that
well you can here
I think you did something uh economical
here where this is an unprecedented
company
this is where everybody in the
production uh benefits from the film's
success and the model in our industry is
not that nor has it really ever been and
I applaud you so much thank you so much
thank you thank you
you're making me very uncomfortable
because it really is about exactly that
last thing you said which is that
it's a complete like uh this is seemed
obvious to me and totally in my
self-interest like the if you the better
the artists are who are the technicians
who are on your crew they make a massive
difference these are artists uh just as
much or greater significance as anyone
in front of the camera it's not a cliche
I understand that intimately I know that
they're you're surrounded by filmmakers
this is not a sculpting or writing a
novel by yourself you are dependent on
everybody you're working with you're
dependent on that environment how it
moves how it's fostered how people feel
whether they're valued and frankly
you'll go to try to do some projects and
all the money to do it is like already
committed to a bunch of like people who
are long gone and that I've always
believed in like I I shouldn't have
gotten paid for the movies that I was in
that didn't work that's not right right
that's not fair you lose money and I
make it should be we should all put it
on the line we should work really hard
collectively and then everybody actors
directors to writers the crew should
have the massive line and share of the
profit because I believe a company can
stay in business
[Applause]
and so it's really about how you do it
and the same goes for in fact uh when I
got
um together with my wife and and looked
at um well what's really valuable here
at least in terms of of these companies
perspectives
um because I believe for example that
like um that my wife was creating more
value than she was being compensated for
that she was Prince the principal driver
of interest in terms of the stuff she
was doing but that when the sort of
broke down and the money got allocated
there were a lot of hands in the pot and
effectively a lot of of ways of her
being taxed by uh people that weren't
contributing the same meaning and value
that she has spent you know 30 years
building and creating in his purse and
that she owns I just you first of all
sorry female moment like you fighting
for your wife I'm like come on please
just stop it well she doesn't need me to
fight for it but I do so we live for
that stuff she just seems like the
pillar of health and wellness and beauty
and sexiness and like awesomeness
[Applause]
like I'm I don't know I like do you tell
you something that's going to upset you
okay
[Music]
foreign